[Musique]
mais on fait le point avec la docteur
caroline ne croit chez les professeurs
au département de microbiologie
immunologie du chu et sainte justine
bonjour docteur couach
oui bonjour donc on apprend ce
rapatriement des canadiens qui se
trouvent sur ce bateau
ceux qui n'ont pas contracté le virus
d'ailleurs il était à selon vous je
pense que c'est une décision qui est
difficile à prendre parce que il ya une
limite entre le moment où on se dit bon
y'a de la transmission sur le bateau
sortons les gens et le début de la
quarantaine ou les gens se disaient
probablement qui on espérait qu'il ait
pas de nouveau que mais quand on est
rendu à 300 quelques et qui est une
évidence de transmission interhumaine
sur le bateau je pense que c'est une
bonne décision
rapatrier nos compatriotes blement la
quarantaine sur le bateau c'était
peut-être pas une bonne idée ou du moins
là il y avait peut-être des ajustements
et y avoir on vient d'entendre une
passagère qui nous disait écouté il y en
a qui n'ont pas les bons masquer les
membres d'équipage nous demander de
remplir des formulaires on nous passe et
les mêmes crayon
et qu'il ya certains officiers qui se
promenaient de cabine en cabine se
trouvent des méthodes qui
malheureusement est de la propagation de
ce virus non oui en fait pour moi le
masque est peut-être moins problématique
compte tenu que la transmission de ce
virus là se fait principalement par
gross gouttelettes et par contact
mais le transfert de petit matériel le
crayon papier de personne en personne
c'est épouvantable on a appris il ya pas
longtemps que ce virus pouvait
probablement survivre sur des surfaces
inanimé de quatre à neuf jours donc plus
facilement imaginer qu'une personne
malade qui manipule le crayon mm c'est
la peau beaucoup de symptômes va laisser
des sécrétions respiratoires et des
virus sur le crayon qui peut ensuite
être passé à la prochaine personne je
pense que l'autre problème aussi c'est
qu'il ya eu un officier de quarantaine
qui était malade dont qui a contracté la
maladie sur le bateau il lui ensuite et
allant de personne en personne devient
un excellent vecteur de transmission et
vous dites 4 à 9 jours c'est énorme
c'est ce virus peut survivre à
l'extérieur du corps humain pendant
autant jo il ya des passagers canadiens
qui ont contracté d'ailleurs levé
reuzeau qui pourront pas être transférés
ici en fait rapatrier vont devoir être
transféré dans un hôpital de la région
est ce que ce serait pas préférable et
est ce que c'est possible de les
rapatrier même s'ils sont attendus
coronavirus tout est toujours possible
c'est quand même plus compliqué c'est un
vol qui est long contenu clic que les
complications sont habituellement
d'ordre respiratoire si jamais une
décompensation en vol parce qu'en plus
moyen moins d'oxygène en voile et où on
peut mettre la sécurité du patient en
danger
c'est sûr que de l'autre côté de
rapatrier tous ces gens là dans nos
systèmes hospitaliers sa mère les
routines notre système hospitalier si
jamais il ya de la transmission locale
on va être aux prises avec les mêmes
problèmes que la chine et le japon
et donc c'est encore une fois là c'est
pas une décision qui est facile à
prendre
oui les ressortissants sont au japon qui
a un excellent système de santé donc n
était pas d'inquiétude pour les familles
de cette quinzaine de personnes de
canadiens qui ont contracté le virus à
bord du bateau qui seront soignés au
japon ce que vous dites c'est que c'est
un très bon système de santé n'y a pas à
s'inquiéter on s'inquiète toujours pour
nous
les avoir ici c'est toujours procès il
m'aimait effectivement c'est un bon
système de santé et donc ils seront bien
traités
bon techniquement comment on rapatrie
ses autres passagers qui pour l'instant
n'ont pas le covan avait russe
il ya quand même plusieurs mesures à
prendre ben ils vont faire je suppose
comme ça avait été fait quand on avait
rapatrié des ressortissants de la
province dubé donc il va y avoir
j'imagine un screening à la porte de
l'avion pour être sûr que personne ne
monte dans l'avion avec des symptômes et
ensuite en cours de vol il devrait y
avoir des évaluations médicales
périodiques des possibilités de mise en
retrait si quelqu'un devenait malades
dans le vol puisqu'il dure quand même
plusieurs heures et un retour encore une
fois dépistage de symptômes et est mise
en quarantaine
ici en fait isolement ici au canada sur
ce qu'on a ce qu'on a c'est là la base
militaire de trenton et l'importance de
cette remise en quarantaine aussi commis
encore des nouveaux cas qui seront
développés sur le bateau on peut pas
prendre cette première période de
quarantaine comme la dernière est
d'ailleurs bon oui sont amenés du côté
de trenton après seront du côté de caen
noir parce que bon pour subir bon en
fait pour vivre cette quarantaine en
terminant docteur couach dites-nous en
chine
on s'amuse sans y avoir une amélioration
de la situation ont dit que le nombre de
nouveaux cas diminue et il ya également
plus 9000
personnes patients touchés qui ont eu
leur congé de l'hôpital c'est le signe
encourageant mais comme le dit depuis
plusieurs jours et j'ai l'impression que
je me rien dire de plus quand on regarde
la courbe a par là la grosse hausse qui
a eu en début de semaine parce que la
chaîne a changé sa définition que elle a
l'air de vouloir s'aplatir mais quand
est-ce qu'elle va s'aplatir complètement
et qu'elle va finir par redescendre j'en
ai aucune idée
ça montre que moins vite mais ça monte
encore alors on va suivre la situation
qui est extrêmement inquiétante mais on
va suivre quand même c'est un ces
canadiens qui vont pouvoir revenir on
verra comment ça va se faire au juste et
k plus précisément caroline courage
professeur au département de
microbiologie et immunologie au chu
sainte-justine merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec aujourd'hui
merci bonne journée